you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on Leech s
org and I'm going to play a 15-2 game
and I already have something to think
about not used to seeing Knight c3 on
move one
how to reply
I guess we'll just put a pond in the
center what made me think about d4 over
anything else is that if it turns into a
d4 like game white won't be playing with
their C pawn any time soon so this could
quickly transpose I guess into a French
on e6 d4 that's what we would have I
could also go towards Knight f6 and
reply
with the d4 Knight f6 key five can be
night once d4
so what path to choose let's see so
these are my two candidate moves I'm not
really considering capturing
I guess we're going to go for a six this
Knight f6 v 5 and d4 line can trade a
lot and will quickly or it is possible
to quickly arrive at an endgame
queenless endgame
let's see what my opponent comes up with
okay so G 3
it's well it's going to be some pressure
bearing down on my Queen side soon how
great of an inconvenience will that
really be
I think I do well too steep still keep
this tension may be simply Knight f6
here
yeah let's put my knight on f6 he can be
kicked of course but we going for this
sort of plan if that happens
all right white is not budging
what to do here Bishop e7 just hold off
on the tension hold off on this
something else maybe c5 and knight c6
and not yet declare my bishop
hmm
I feel like a computer I don't know how
helpful Nexus but I feel like a computer
would just play Bishop to e7 or you know
no hold on you know what else a computer
might do D for D fourth maybe d3 now
that the bishop isn't here wonder if
that's something I could do D 492 d3
pawn takes Queen takes I think my queen
will be flushed out of there though its
Knight f4 and then white will be able to
get in d4 and have a strong pawn Center
so in the end the result is my D pawn
exchange for the C pawn and then White
has a majority if you a different story
if I could have maintained a piece here
and make life difficult for white to
expand with the D pawn but I don't see
that happening
okay I'm going to start off with Bishop
to e7
who is this player do they have yeah
they've been around for a while many
different categories okay
so what are some candidate moves for
white d3 takes maybe push
maybe f4 although on f4 I think white
would want to be in a position to me
that pawn takes with pawn takes and
maintain some type of duo if the F pawn
is on is rolling and is on f4 and I
could eliminate the e4 pawn I think this
move loses some sting you know if I
could break up potential pawn duo's and
F pawn f4 e for duo
so
expect something like d3 before f4 if
that's even an idea for white seems
pretty standard of course you could go
with the d4 this will allow me to bite
at something if white is trying to go
after my throat on the kingside trying
to attack me I think in d3 is like it's
more modest looking but it looks to
simply reinforce the strong e4 point and
then maybe slowly expand one day my
knight position can be brought into
question so here we go with d3
so I mean this is turning into a a Kings
Indian attack like formation normally
the knight is on d2 not c3
so what I could try to do here is figure
out some of the differences between
these two posts for one I could play d4
with a strike that one get that if the
knight is on D too
sure there's more differences but yeah
just a quick note if I want to change
the structure slightly close it up I
could get that in with a punch I think
in nearly all situations I want my C
pawn contributing so let's uh let's get
him involved I think I could just do
that straight away I'm a little bit
concerned c5 takes takes Bishop here
trying to undermine my point here but I
could always move him if White's going
to give up the bishop pair let's get my
C pawn rolling there's some delay with
this King night so I have some concern
like if I needed to reinforce a d5 point
maybe this is a maneuver into f4 one way
or the other I would expect one of these
two moves I think this is more universal
it stays out of any of the pond any of
the white pawns from E to frees up a
quick f4 on h3 this will often be a
desirable move for white h3 once you fee
and cut out castles this is the flight
square
nice little home on h2
I'd expect this okay I know they're
going straight for pressure on my night
so this is already threatening some
stuff namely to capture and after I take
here to take on this square but I don't
believe that that is actually a threat
come to think of it because if my bishop
is here I could always look to let's say
eliminate the night or or grab this
super valuable heart of whites queenside
structure the b2 pond so I think I still
do well to keep this tension not push
not capture just hold my ground on my
best pond I would say my fourth rank on
in the center d5 and maybe I could just
go with castles here castles or maybe
Knight to c6 can I am like am I going to
go Queen side castles I don't think
castling queenside I'm okay with No
committing my king I'll go I'll go Kings
side now I'll show my hand so don't
think that this would be a good choice
I'm already Castle Dwight is not they're
not banking any material with this
chop-chop-chop-chop
Bishop takes that would be just flat-out
loss I take the night with check the
only defender and then scoop up the
bishop if the other order is captures
captures Bishop takes Bishop takes and
then Knight takes I have at minimum
Bishop takes b2
they're accustomed move and also I could
look for a rook to e8 move don't know
how much of an inconvenience that would
be I would develop and block and be
quick to get out of the pin but III
think I'm fine with the opening up of
the position I haven't worked out all
the details but I think I'll minimum be
able to keep the material balanced
so what is what is white chewing on here
at a later stage this could be a threat
so I mean I think it's fine right now at
this present moment but a move or two
down the line I'm I'm going to have to
question
these capturing sequences on d5 with
every move how are things changing once
the knight is deployed here would white
then be threatening this I should
probably be working on those details
right now what would I do on this pretty
natural-looking Knight to e2 move and
there we go
and I think I could
I could still hold ground on this
capture let's see knight c6 pawn takes
on takes
Bishop takes Knight I can have other
options come to think of it you know
what I do have on knight c6 I'm just
going to play it without much
calculation this time around another
option I have I'm just realizing is that
on now maybe I did miss calculate there
there might have been an option to to
capture I was thinking for a moment on
takes I could take with the knight and
then I'm on the bishop and I'm Bishop
takes Bishop I can recapture like this
if anything alright so do I still hold
off on this I think maybe white is uh is
close now to
winning a pond right around this point
with takes takes Bishop takes Bishop
takes and then Bishop takes pawn the
difference now is that when I take here
white can replace the defender of d5 and
I don't have any ways to show let's say
compensation with Bishop h3 stopping
castling now likes of course already
castled
I'm wondering about default in d4 here I
think this Knight will find it a bit
awkward come to think of it he's going
to have to go home
grab a little space and maybe look to
change the structure further yeah I'm
actually leaning towards this I think
with the bishop out and about and the
likelihood that a dark square bishop
exchanges to occurs yeah you know it's
there and if I start to position pawns
on dark squares this is my bad bishop so
that would be a desirable exchange d4
here 'if I've and then maybe a knight
move these guys are exchanged there's a
lot to weigh of course this is a big
decision
d4 white will be heading on the Kings
side I will have this square I could try
to get in there I will have to play h4
but I think this is going to turn out to
be a race position if I go in for d4 I
don't think that this move helps me
takes pawn takes and so I mean I could
consider that that's a let's let's make
it maybe a bit more of a strategic
battle let's go in for deform maybe try
to highlight one of the downsides with
the knight deployment to c3 instead of
d2 it's like a free move and I acquire a
little bit of space
I got a pond in whites got a pawn in
White's house
I think there's many other options this
would run into moves that I would like
to play maybe five I want to expand on
the queenside so if I could continue to
expand on the queenside with little jabs
I'm all for that
so night here 'if I've is what I'm
thinking
'if I've is f4 that's probably already a
loss
because I'm thank G for dark square
bishop exchange and what are you doing
about a knight arriving on e3 he
basically morphs into a rook when he's
on e3 probably more he's probably worth
more than a rook if he gets to e3 so
before any f4 move Dwight will have to
insert h3 to stop this maneuver and in
the meantime here here if the knight
goes here real quick I mean this is a
pretty standard maneuver I'm surprised
that white is thinking so much on this
move here is there some computer-like
move with Knight a for preparing to take
take and then take here
I feel like a computer would be like
there's no way I'm moving backwards I'm
moving forwards and threatening stuff
okay here we go
isn't why you actually just lost them I
mean what's the plan here because I
don't have to take with the bishop
doesn't b5 just win the knight after all
this am I just going to be winning some
material how deep is this this line here
I don't get it
it's true when I played b5 my nights
unprotected and I'll have to be
concerned about that move but I could
meet Eve I've with night here
I don't see it what's the story here
well how many squares does the knight
have when he's on the edge at most four
he's not going to these two he's not
going here so this is the only sensitive
point really b5 how can why try to
complicate this doesn't seem to do it I
go here trying to take advantage of some
other pin I can always take
no I think the complications are just
always work out in my favor I'm always
the one to initiate the captures
five
takes Knight pawn takes Bishop
um
and from that position if this advance
comes in I could always play Bishop b7
at that point or Bishop to d7 Queen to
c7 b v e5 here Bishop takes Bishop
Knight takes Bishop and my knight is
defended and this Knight is still under
fire my king would be compromised a bit
not having this Jeep on around but where
is there a single attacker near my Kings
side I have to watch out for this but
that's a it's many moves and I only need
two to really cover the criticals
squares I don't get it I think that this
is just a blunder what am I missing
okay well
I think maybe why I don't know I'm just
going to do it spent enough time on it
maybe white was thinking that I'm takes
I have to take with the bishop in that
way there would then be e5 that's the
only thing I could come up with maybe
unless I'm still missing something but
if I had to guess I would think that
white miscalculated that there's a takes
and assumed that I would take with the
bishop now that I wouldn't even be right
because I would just be dropping upon
take stakes here double attack against
my f6 and c6 points so they're back into
a think here only nine moves in expense
more than ten minutes
find the Night Moves it's pretty typical
for me I always have to work my way
through the opening blind seems so well
let's see if how white is going to try
to complicate that's what I'm waiting
for right around this point
is a king safety going to be an issue
for me at all
let's see if what kind of stuff white
tries to inject into this position
okay
so they're going for that but oh wait a
second what am I talking about on this
Bishop takes if I take like this there's
night takes here
okay so night here Bishop takes Bishop I
take with the Queen and defend here
well I believe I have to play Knight to
d5 here yeah that was silly thinking
that I could do this and defend here I
still need to cover c5 and I can on here
Knight takes I could take the bishop I
think I just do this I mean I would have
played that pretty pretty fast if it was
a bullet game I think that's just the
right thing to do and yeah let's
recapture and now we got this okay
Oh
so that's how this is working I'm not
winning any material okay
interesting there is that enough I take
like this the night recaptures so
actually I'm just like losing here or
something now after all that after all
that in the end I'm going to be losing
and my time situation is horrible okay
hmm
all right so takes the night recaptures
and I feel like I'm in trouble then
takes takes both of these points or hit
hmm
takes here pawn takes Bishop hmm
pawn takes pawn and my knight has to
move here he gets kicked away and then
I'm losing c6 alright my choices are
super limited now I don't think that
this is a good line me initiating these
captures end up in some 10
maybe I could get that e5 pawn I feel
like maybe I should try to hang on to
this d4 point
on takes Knight pawn takes Knight pawn
takes pawn Bishop takes pawn and then
[Music]
Bishop here maybe I have some
compensation one day I'm going to I'm
going to go in for this try to hang on
to my d4 point you know I'm going to
take here he's uh probably going to be
struck out soon so maybe if I come out
down upon at some stage I could hope for
maybe a light square bishop exchange and
work with something in here the weakened
f3 and h3 squares
I must say that that sequence right
there pretty much rattled me some
emotionally because I was thinking I'm
going to be up material and yeah it's
just not the case so I'm going to be
down material very soon
to try for night b4 which might not be
so bad
this will strike out d3 and I think I
made the right decision in these
complications at least that last
sequence to hang on to my d4 point and
now try to aim towards some attack this
is something long-term but something
involving these light squares with once
these guys are off I have the cozier
home
maybe I could even pick up this pawn
that's what I'm threatening right now
yeah so that's nice if Queen takes pawn
I could take here there's another Avenue
to attack d3
can maybe even look into 83 but 83 maybe
blight just takes and denies me the be
Foursquare it's an interesting
interesting position may probably just
f4 here is best what I do on that f4 on
f4 I get well that weakens this square
so I saying earlier about a night
drifting in here well there's multiple
squares that cannot get to e3 so on f4
that weakens e3 I could look into this
light square Bishop exchange focusing on
f3 H 3 and maybe circle my night into
the e3 square if there's a pawn on f4
guards this pawn but it makes this night
not so great it takes away one of the
best squares from the night this pawn
controls this these two squares
well this structure controls c 3 and d 4
so I go with Queen takes pawn so should
I just took should probably pick up the
pawn one two three four five six one two
three four five six seven I'm down upon
win the pawn back and yeah welcome a
light square Bishop exchange
it can't be so bad and Bishop takes
Bishop Queen takes this is going to be
really tough to deal with now
night is already eyeing up these squares
this is I think white is in a tough spot
I'm in a tough spot time lines
got the two a two second increment but
positionally I think that this is
this is good for me
for right now
I'm going to say it again I feel like a
computer would play Knight to f4 you
know not to helping my queen to get on
this diagonal to I up at the weak
squares makes sense you know I won't
have time Knight f4 Bishop Knight f4
Bishop takes Bishop Knight takes I don't
have time to go here here the knight
would be striking in my queen say Knight
f4 Bishop takes Knight takes maybe first
Queen here I'm on the night and stilled
upon and I still have the f3 squared a
later stage I don't believe that the
knight could be maintained on d5 can
always challenge him further
okay Knight f4 it is Oh Kate okay is
there anything fancy going on when the
Knights on d5 probably he's within
checking distance so to watch out for
some fancy check on e7 I don't have a
lot of time I should probably just take
the bishop and play Queen to d6
that's what I'm going to do
night check here kingi - don't see what
the follow-up is let's take the bishop
and then get on with my reaction move
clean d6
please don't fork me so - a queen here
Queen takes Knight here but I have my
knight
he's a good guy - he's in my house
though I don't like that look at this
wow so I could win a pawn now right
material is bounced and that's a super
weakening move no scoop up the night
scooped up a pond and everybody's happy
I don't think healthiest of ponds but
I kinda have to just go into bullet mode
right around here have anything better
well what's wrong which is taking this
pawn hang on you know what's keeping me
from just scooping up this pawn and
saying why not take your knight one move
later
or going in here keeping my night and
then just trying to kill you this night
just trapped isn't the night just
trapped if I go here there's clean here
fanciness let's take the night so fancy
I guess we're just going to
I'm going to go here I want to keep my
queen central I take the took the palm
at the Queen there's just going to be
some tempo so there's one attackers your
defenders now there's two attackers is
your defenders he's not going anywhere I
don't think it's true he could be
captured but it shouldn't White be a
little bit concerned about this kind of
stuff notice I went with that rope
because I want to keep f7 defended just
going straight in for this stuff are
they trying to burn my time
so yeah I guess so and we have five
seconds
they have two connected passers I really
don't know how to assess this they're
going to scoop up my c5 pawn let's give
this check I'm gonna need a flight
square soon huh and get a time gainer in
there how about alright I'm done with
the time gainers let's get a flight
score and I would have gone here if the
Queen wasn't defending so I could maybe
get to g2 completely balanced now I
don't know if I could afford a queen
exchange
a little bit hesitant to move my off
rook because this my pawn will put
pressure on that really soon
I'm going to need to get my rep lying
though yeah
for starters and just backup
yeah and tricky and to safer King so
well now that there's not as much
pressure on f7 let's get my wreck
playing huh
clean here at least throws a punch
should look to still push him a little
bit more open up this diagonal towards
their King have both diagonals opened up
towards their king for some checks I
could look to defend f7 laterally now my
queen defends this diagonal in case my
King is flushed off of this 8th ranks I
like that let's push I am on this now
they just going to keep pushing the rook
is unprotected so pawn push Queen a4 is
something how would they defend that
position if they push the pawn just
going there huh let's go to protected
square
also maybe this is a move right I feel
like this should be wedding check and
then maybe here okay that's a check like
own for that I got to go really simple
now I will take one of the two connected
pastors and try to win three versus two
well also just I have to look at this a
little bit different right because my
time situation now they're going to get
behind the pond but they're going to be
a long ways off from getting that pond
rolling
the rook is in mobile and mine is not
my engine ah
get my king playing and we're just going
to go maybe here
yeah I want to go too far I don't want
to love that pawn - just keep pushing I
don't want to allow the king to approach
my rook with tempo so easily let's say
have to work before
rook has to budge again that
helps me create two connected passed
pawns now yes so this is now definitely
winning I know how to win this even with
a handful of seconds as well
that increments so this is already close
to worth of rook once they're here and
white is just a mile away from really
posing any danger I guess I'll go with
this one I'm close to now I'll come all
the way back
the rook isn't behind so
it's pretty straightforward here keep
pushing my connected passers and they
just resigned
Wow and as mentioned a bit of a
rollercoaster a bit of a roller coaster
emotionally at that middle game position
when I was thinking I was winning with
material and then why don't I have to do
I had to adjust I thought it was going
to be down upon and then turned up up
upon had that weird imbalance to
connected passage but they were so far
back in that end game I had I had a
passed pawn single guy they had a more
exposed King so I'm just throwing that
out there these are some of the things
that uh some of the characteristics of
the position that helps me determine
who's maybe better so maybe before I
just dive in well no I think I'm okay
with just jumping right in here yeah
this'll this would be a good one to go
over I think I made the correct decision
here I don't think that why worked out
all these details there's a lot of
there's many different variations and it
seemed like this was played it wasn't
played right away but I don't know
there's a lot to consider there I don't
know why I was thinking I just take here
that I'm still on this and I was
forgetting when I take here I'm not
controlling that and the night just goes
here I think I'm in trouble if I do that
capture on passant here and then now
there's some serious pressure against my
dog and I think I'll be losing some some
material there if I would have captured
so okay well let me dive into the
analysis here
and um there is yeah this is it's been
so long since I played a 15 minute game
on Leech s that there's a new well
here's the graph a rocky road but I
guess I was a Lisa okay
well the move it didn't like is the one
that I thought it was going to be like
winning material it wasn't a fan of b5
after Knight to a4 like something else
let me turn the computer off and make
use of this a fairly new feature learn
from your mistakes I haven't really
investigate looked at this much but so I
guess this is the story with it learn
from my mistakes
apparently considers three three
position types are three of my moves to
be mistakes so that would be some I
guess I'm the mistake sir determines the
term mistake is determined by the
fluctuation in the evaluation so if it
shifts I don't know what the exact
number is but maybe if it ships shifts
about a hundred well let's say I buy one
pond or a single point maybe they
consider that a mistake I'm not sure
what the threshold is for that but
anyhow they go back to this position
here so I don't really have to go
through the beginning of the game and
I'm going to just make use of this
little feature learn from your mistakes
and this is the first one's covering so
b5 was played find a better move for
black alright so I'm going to devote
just a little bit of time maybe a minute
to trying to come up with something else
here because uh
yeah apparently b5 is a mistake there so
what is something better I could do this
over again knowing that white has a way
forward
hmm
I'm thinking maybe Knight to d7
welcoming a dark square bishop exchange
getting out of e5 with tempo
night here Bishop takes Queen takes and
then maybe I'm threatening this month
I wonder if 97 is a is a better move for
black
hmm
think it is
I'm going to say there's many different
moves that you can play but let's just
see if this is they consider that okay I
guess that's one of many different ways
to improve there could be the case that
that was the only improvement but I
don't think that's the position type
we're looking at whether it's an only
move type position for example I think I
could have played let's say rook to b8
but it allows for Bishop takes Knight
and I'd have to route my structure if I
still want to defend c5 so
Knight to d7 they consider that a good
move evaluation wise what is it saying
I'll have a look at that in a little bit
but let's just go on to the next mistake
mistake two of three and yeah okay so
well
what would also factored into this
position was my time I felt that there
would have been something different here
I wanted to do this well you know what
they're going to I know what they're
going to say they're going to say just
grab material you idiot that's what the
computers going to say just take d3
clown it's a matter with you who cares
if the Queen goes here and has some
fancy way to get it and get the Queen
back it's just going to say take d3 okay
um yeah I should have captured d3 yeah I
really want
to get this in the g4 into into here
still stuck in fact after Knight takes
pawn Queen c6 I could play Queen d8
Queen takes Queen rook takes Queen the
night is under fire the knight is
running really short on squares you
would have to go to check King f8 and
the night runs away I'm playing this
position when I'm up upon and yeah okay
so I should have just pulled the trigger
on Knight takes perfect that's a simple
correction and I guess we'll just have a
look at the the third mistake ooh
apparently this is already a negative
7.2 position with rook here so I'd
something other than moving my rook here
probably to e8 r c8 is my improvement I
don't have any good checks right now
Queen takes rook is is there
I guess rook here is what they would
suggest why am i lean more towards c8
over e8 maybe both are still good but
yeah I guess to have the seventh or the
second rank squared mind I don't get
that when the rook is on e8
see a time looking to get straight in
here so I think the improvement would be
ripped to ca just going to put it on
that
yeah they consider that a good move okay
well those are the three or does it say
done reviewing black mistakes do it
again review them white mistakes I'm not
going to go in that direction but yeah
that's pretty neat that you could look
from both both players perspectives what
more to go through I just want to kind
of skim let's clear that up just want to
skim
is a good thing to have by the way I
don't know if I had it running on
previous videos but in your settings you
could have it to show two lines I think
it's good to have two lines here for
those when you're reviewing to have when
there's a position type where there's an
only move having two lines here will
will tell you if there's an only move
present in the position if you know well
we might even arrive at well we'll
probably see that in action as I'm going
through this but is it a fan of d4 yeah
right right here it's a fan of that
decision and this is a big decision
not like critical for me I have to find
that move but it cuts the board in half
it takes the game in a much different
direction and yeah that's what I thought
might like to be one would have been
better I guess going here yeah I mean
close to the same but there's far more
to calculate here because he is really
short on squares but getting back to the
evaluation thing you'll see sometimes
it'll say like for example is white
maybe close to making an only move here
oh my goodness I have another decision I
could go here okay so right here here's
an example this is pretty much an only
move when you see one line this is the
best line the top one negative point to
still tiny advantage for black and the
next one is minus 1.9 you know that
white pretty much has to go with this
move so that's why it's nice to have two
lines running you go four more lines but
I like just keeping it at 2 so C 4 was
in fact played did I make the correct
decision here ok maybe it would change
but it likes this therefore they're
pretty equal huh I I wanted to keep this
pawn around my furthest advance pawn so
that they chop their recapture night f4
interesting that would have been an
improvement maybe I don't know if this
would show up in the in a list of white
mistakes taking on this square maybe the
improvement is
Knight to f4 so Bishop takes and yeah
I'm still holding an advantage here and
now it's pretty much winning yeah - two
point four right there take stakes here
after f4 there's no there's no good
square here for the night
best is the suggested Knight takes pawn
here I just took and it's just holding
half pond maybe upon advantage for me
but it's just not clear they have a more
vulnerable King but just two minor
pieces are two major pieces around some
defense still holding an advantage but
not decisive yeah let me let me just
look at this last position really
the pond and yeah it does want to go
with this queen c6 and yeah I mean if I
do this there's a check my king would
have to go in the corner that said
that's why I mean I didn't point this
out but that's why I would want to play
at this point rook here this now pretty
much forces Queen takes Queen I'm on the
night and there's just no squares he's
in the senator but the backward moves
are taken away the forward moves you
know they're no good at this very moment
so white has to go with this and now on
the check at least I can move in the
direction I would like to go because it
isn't the end game and that is towards
the center but anyhow yeah I should just
picked up a pawn take the pawn on d3 and
still be on the night I took the night
and where or did it turn losing four
team lights
I was doing a couple time gainers I
don't use that tactic nearly as much as
the time burners but we are playing with
increment and I get my pond rolling and
I guess that's the game loser this is
probably good as well but not as not as
good as looking to get here to two pigs
on the second and some possibilities to
maybe pick up this loose piece on d1
what would I do on Queen to F - it's RT
yeah I could just still jump right in
there
yeah clean here rook to c2 and now here
you know here's another thing even in
some variation if even if I lose my F 2
points not the end of the world can
always scoot up here yeah so this
combined with white having ulnar ball
king is an issue isn't it whoo-hoo
what's the story if let's say the Queen
goes here could give checks check there
oh look at that nice
what's the story here I wasn't going to
be coming up with this exact variation
what's the what's the key idea
ten a little stepladder ah that's pretty
Swift I like that a little bit over all
right
first first provoke h3 now this is
weakened and then we have this little
zigzag to the point where I could scoop
up g3
and then once you're on g3 there's not
going to be a defense here it's already
suggesting this kind of stuff that's a
cool little maneuver right at the end
there but yeah I just went with whatever
was instinctual for me keeping my rook
behind the pond with rook to d4 and
cutting out the Queen which is still
okay a tiny bit better for me but not
decisive and I just wanted to go in for
something like this where it was simple
for me to play and yeah this is one of
these rare cases where the rookie is
behind the past pawn but it's the rook
it's my Brooke who's actually better
positioned because he can't move until
the rook until the King comes all the
way over here and that's a lot of time I
think it's winning from here does it
like rook here yeah I figured it'd be
like one of these squares I wasn't sure
should I come here here but yeah I think
I could come all the way back and it's
still winning
okay maybe not I'd have to give it a
little bit of time to think but yeah
just going to a point where the King has
to work a little bit and the position
where the pawn can't just keep on
pushing you know - all the way down to
b7 so maybe in the end of a tiny bit of
an important decision playing rook there
and yeah these pawns as it turns out is
just they're too fast and it's losing
but just one last note this only helps
speed up the you know the creation of a
passed pawn just like you would see in
middle game positions where it's
opposite sides castling that's why they
say don't move pawn in front of your
King because what do you want to do in
opposite sides castle positions you want
to open lines towards the enemy King
well if you move pawns that are in front
of your King it's going to be that much
easier for your opponent to initiate a
pawn break a pawn capture and in this
case this was really helpful because h5
and then g5 I think I said it in the
game as soon as h3 was played that this
is just going to help me out if he's
still here it's going to take a little
bit more time I have to spend that much
anymore Tempe before I have connected
past palms so that hit really fast and
it's just game over from here it
wouldn't even be a race if it were to go
further I mean as mentioned I can always
just sacrifice like this but yeah these
guys are just super valuable
okay well it's been a while for a 15-2
game I enjoy playing these type
hopefully enjoy watching these kind
videos feel free as usual to leave any
feedback in the comments section below
hope you're having a great day and I
will catch you soon that's all for now
take care bye
you